as ordinary Americans cope with the
economic impacts of coronavirus the
White House announced Dave was pushing
Congress to make immediate cash payments
to struggling Americans what we've heard
from hardworking Americans many
companies have now shut down whether its
bars or restaurants Americans need cash
now and the president wants to get cash
now and I mean now in the next two weeks
Congress has already put forward a bill
to provide sick leave as well as food
assistance to children and the elderly
it still needs to pass the
republican-controlled Senate before us
President Donald Trump can sign it into
law but the new proposed payments which
also need to be approved by Congress
would be part of a package worth more
than a trillion dollars include help for
the airline and other industries hit
hard by the slowdown in business this is
worse than 9/11 for the airline industry
we're going big with this invisible
enemy we don't want airlines going out
of business we don't want people losing
their jobs the hotel industry has also
been hard hit on Tuesday marriott the
world's largest hotel company started
furloughing thousands of employees as
their hotels see fewer customers but
it's not just the economy that has the
White House worried it says public
health remains a priority on standby in
New York the Army Corps of Engineers to
increase Hospital capacity in response
to the pandemic New York remains one of
the states with a high cluster of
coronavirus cases my hunch is it would
probably be quicker if it's done at the
state or local level but if we can do it
quicker we should we're prepared to do
that but I think at this point the key
is speed still there are signs it will
be weeks if not months before life
returns to normal
loved events like the Kentucky Derby
horse race now delayed until September
and in an election year the Ohio
presidential nominating contest was also
called off the American Red Cross on
Tuesday also put out a call for blood
donations the coronavirus task
here at the White House says the next
two weeks will be critical for
containing the virus that's why it's
urging young people to abide by public
health warnings to ensure more
vulnerable Americans aren't exposed
kimberly hellcat al Jazeera the White
House